hey guys right now i'm going to show you
guys a quick little tutorial in hd um
how to set a hotkey for screen capturing
using cam studio screen recorder
so a simple way to do this it's very
easy is to open up screen recorder open
up cam studio whether it's from your
rocket dock or from your start menu
open it up and you'll get this box of
course
click on options and the very last one
is keyboard shortcuts
clicking on this will bring up a window
with all your hotkeys
and if you're watching this in hd
hopefully you can see that this is a
record or pause key this is the stop key
the cancel recording key the next layout
previous layout and show our hide layout
keys
so i've selected control f1 to be my uh
beginning and pause recording
recording key in time studio and ctrl f2
to actually be stopping so this just
makes a little easier so you don't have
to edit your video so much so you don't
have to actually come down here and
double click it and then hit pause or
stop or you don't have to right click
and then pause or stop the video from
there
it's much much easier
and it goes a little bit smoother if you
just use your hotkeys
so that's how you quickly set a keyboard
shortcut for recording in camstudio hope
you found this helpful go ahead and
subscribe peace